last night et was exclusively with the
performer seconds after they stepped off
the stage including the couple with
stars in their eyes
Gwen Stefani and Blake Shelton
Blake Shelton you know how you not put a
ring on that woman's finger I'm just
throwing that out there that's just me
that was like mr. t like that um
actually there's totally room cuz check
this out there's a ring on every finger
except that one
when was looking like the Queen of
Hearts in a sheer white gown holding
Blake's hand sharing a romantic moment
on stage no wonder he looked lovestruck
backstage whoa look at this that's not
just from years of drinking that's from
performing with Gwen Stefani on the
Grammys when how was it only et had this
exclusive spot backstage revealing what
you didn't see on TV last night that was
like like dancing with God himself
you saw Liz Oh slay the audience and win
a Grammy with seconds later how was this
moment after ariana grande's electric
performance she got cheers as she had it
straight to her dressing room I also
made a fashion statement wearing four
different outfits throughout the night
on the red carpet she had this mic drop
moment everyone's done incredibly this
year I'm like looking around like
okay that's a party we got you we got
cheer two seconds nice I do mic drop but
when this party was over it was Billy's
big night even though she didn't think
it would be I'm ready to lose all of
them I love you haven't even thought
about the speech what do you mean you're
gonna win I'm not but thank you yep that
didn't happen
instead the 18 year old made Grammy
history as the youngest artist ever to
take all four of the top honors album
new song and record of the year plus
best new artist my brother he's the how
do you how do you take in this mom oh
you don't know a couple years from now
we'll be like remember that one time
[Music]